Joseph Roden Joseph says hey David
why will stupid Democrats like Bernie
and Warren insist on weakening our
military this is one of those questions
that really requires a little bit of
historical context to understand and the
historical context is that going back
decades now there has been an attempt
from the right to feminize the left and
what we're really talking about is the
feminization of democratic male
candidates if you look at 2004 and you
look at John Kerry John Kerry was a
military veteran the right loves to talk
about so-called war heroes we can debate
whether somebody who served in the
military is or isn't a war hero by
default reasonable people can argue
about that is merely serving your
country an act of heroism does depend on
what you whatever right that that
conversation doesn't matter by the
definition that the right used John
Kerry was a war hero and yet they
feminized him they talked about him
speaking French they talked about him
you know being European in whatever ways
they minimized his military credentials
the Swift Boat Veterans came out and
attacked carry around his claims
regarding military service and this is
all part of this movement that exists to
feminize the left as being afraid of war
as being afraid of guns as shying away
irrationally from violence so that's
where you get questions like this why
will Democrats weaken our military and
of course the truth is that our military
is so over funded it is so many orders
of magnitude inflated beyond what it
needs to be to still be the strongest
and biggest military in the world that
anyone who says you know what I'm
concerned about how much we're spending
on the military I'm concerned about the
foreign policy the morale the legal the
ethical implications of how far the
tentacles of our military spread
they are accused like what we are seeing
here of wanting to weaken our military
when the truth is that even significant
cuts to the military would not weaken
the military the u.s. would be more than
able to protect itself from any kind of
attack but there's another element that
I want to talk about here there's this
idea that a democratic president like
Bernie or Warren the right likes to push
this if push came to shove and the
correct decision was a military
engagement they simply wouldn't do it
they'd paint a picture of potential
Democratic presidents as people who the
US would be under attack
domestically one of our allies a base
whatever and the military would come to
president Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren they'd say Madam President mr.
president were under attack we've got to
do something and Bernie or Warren would
sit back and say no we're not going to
do anything we will allow ourselves to
simply be attacked and people to be
killed this is not how things work I
know that with Donald Trump who operates
unilaterally going completely against
the recommendations of the Pentagon and
the State Department and whoever it
seems as though that's something that
presidents typically do the reality is
that both Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren have made no indication that they
are pacifists a priori and they have
made it abundantly clear that if they
were president when military advisers
come to them and they explain the
situation on the ground they would
basically follow the advice of their
generals as Donald Trump likes to say so
the question is problematic at its core
it relates to this historical
feminization and weakening that
Republicans have sort of successfully
done the Democrats when it comes to
foreign policy because hey Democrats
don't want illegal Wars never ending
Wars occupations in the wrong country
that didn't actually do it all of that
stuff they've feminized and may framed
as weak Democrats but more importantly
they also like to pretend that a
progressive president like a Bernie or
would ignore the advice of experts if
anything the problem we have right now
is that Trump ignores advice from
experts Bernie or Warren would actually
listen to what experts are saying and we
should be glad for that so Joseph I
don't know if you're asking this
question in good faith or not but
assuming that it's in good faith you
appear to have been bamboozled by some
of the right wing talking points on this
issue that does it for today we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
become a member or a patron to get
instant access go to join pakman.com
right now takes under one minute to sign
up